legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting immobile before president
Trump's photo-op at st. John's Church in
front of Lafayette Square which resulted
in peaceful protesters being gassed with
chemicals and shot with rubber bullets
he appeared in the Rose Garden behind
the White House to outline his response
to the protests that have roiled this
nation president Trump threatened to
take dramatic action to quell the
protests including invoking the
insurrection Act of 1807 which allegedly
would allow him to deploy the military
to crack down on protesters and rioters
President Trump did not officially
invoke the insurrection act but he did
use his unique authority within the
district to make a serious show of force
in recent days for reasons that should
be relatively obvious people have
debated how much authority the president
has to use the military for civilian law
enforcement purposes and in addition to
the insurrection act you've probably
heard people mention the Posse Comitatus
Act and claimed that the president
actually doesn't have authority to
invoke the Armed Forces and riots and
protests well I'm here to deliver the
sobering news that the president
actually has a lot of authority to use
the military against the American people
but whether he can do it and whether he
should do it are two completely separate
issues
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because I can personally
confirm that there are a lot of American
troops operating on American soil as we
speak
and by the way I started my research for
this video by going to what I think is
by far the best resource for national
security law and that's a blog called
law fair it's simply Bar None the best
resource for answers to national
security law questions you can go there
at law fair blog com I highly recommend
it so let's start with the Posse
Comitatus Act does it stop the president
from using the military domestically now
it's easy to confuse the insurrection
Act of 1807 with the Posse Comitatus Act
in fact you'll often see people say that
the PCA actually bars the president from
using the military in domestic matters
and there's some truth to it but it's
largely false section 13 85 of Title 18
of the u.s. code states whoever except
in cases under circumstances expressly
authorized by the Constitution or act of
Congress willfully uses any part of the
army or Air Force as a Posse Comitatus
or otherwise to execute the laws shall
be fined under this title or in prison
not more than two years or both now a
big part of a lawyer's job is analyzing
the text of laws and judicial opinions
and you'll notice that this language
provides a bar unless there is a
specific act of Congress or something in
the Constitution that allows it and this
is one of those situations where the
exception predominates the rule and
generally the Posse Comitatus Act
prevents the military from participating
in traditional law enforcement
activities however Congress has enacted
many many exceptions to the pca to allow
the military to assist civilian law
enforcement agencies in enforcing the
laws for example the Department of
Defense can provide some support to law
enforcement agencies battling drug
crimes and organized crime the military
may also defend their own bases and
property it's one of those instances
where the exceptions tend to swallow the
rule it's kind of like the rule against
hearsay sure there's a general rule
against hearsay being admissible in
court but frankly there are so many
different exceptions that it's actually
the rarity where you can't get the
hearsay admitted into court as evidence
but the biggest exception to the pca is
the insurrection act itself so let's
talk about that the insurrection act of
10:07 actually refers to five pieces of
legislation that are found in ten USC
sections 251 through 255 the law sets
forth several scenarios that a president
may use to justify deploying the
military domestically now before the
president can invoke the insurrection
act he quote must first issue a
proclamation ordering the insurgents to
disperse within a limited time if the
situation does not resolve itself then
the president may issue an executive
order to send in troops now it's
important to note that the insurrection
act actually dates back to a time when
municipal police departments didn't
really exist in this country and so it
made sense that there would be times
when the federal government would need
to send military personnel to help out
with state or local issues now given
that in the modern era every state and
every municipality has a police
department one might question the
utility of having the insurrection act
remaining on the books now the oldest
section of this law is section 254 which
was enacted in 1792 to give George
Washington authority to call forth the
militia to repel invasions suppress
insurrections or enforce the laws
Congress was initially reluctant to
grant even Washington this Authority so
they required that he would first need
to give insurgents of warning to
disperse and although President Trump
has explicitly threatened to invoke the
insurrection act if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents
then I will deploy the United States
military and quickly solve the problem
for them to date it's not clear that his
speech qualifies as a proclamation
required under this Act section 251 of
the insurrection act deals with federal
aid for state governments it combines
two laws from the earliest days of the
Republic one was a law used to suppress
the Whiskey Rebellion of 1794 this was
an uprising of farmers and distillers
who protested at federal whiskey tax
after years of protestors tarring and
feathering tax collectors and destroying
property President Washington was given
authority to call forth the militia upon
the request of a governor or state
legislature the second part of this law
was enacted in 1807 at the request of
President Jefferson and allows a
president to call up a standing army as
well as the militia which brings us to
section 252 which regards the use of
militia
armed forces to enforce a federal
authority section 252 was enacted in
1861 at the request of President Lincoln
to increase presidential authority to
use the militia and Regular Army to
suppress insurrections and enforce the
laws this law was the legal basis for
waging the Civil War and the law allows
the President to use federal troops on
his own initiative and act on his own
judgment without having to wait for the
request of a governor and in fact you're
seeing a lot of governor's on TV
recently stating that they are not going
to request federal troops or federal aid
under the insurrection Act the thing is
for most of the insurrection act it
doesn't require Govnah torial approval
that brings us to section 253
interference with state and federal law
in 1869 Congress added section 253 the
request of President Grant to empower
him to use federal troops to suppress
the Ku Klux Klan during Reconstruction
section 253 States quote the president
by using the militia or the Armed Forces
or both or by any other means shall take
such measures as he considers necessary
to suppress in a state any insurrection
domestic violence unlawful combination
or conspiracy if it one so hinders the
execution of the laws of that state and
of the United States within the state
then any part or class of its people is
deprived of a right privilege immunity
or protection named in the Constitution
and secured by law and the constituted
authorities of that state are unable
fail or refuse to protect that right
privilege or immunity or to give that
protection or to opposes or obstructs
the execution of the laws United States
or impedes the course of justice under
those laws and you can tell by the plain
text of this language that that is
incredibly broad authority and that in a
situation where you have peaceful
protesters and rioting and looting going
on at the exact same time that it's not
surprising that someone might use the
unlawful activity as a pretext to
curtail the lawful activity as well now
originally there were two fairly large
limits on the use of military personnel
by invoking the insurrection act by the
president the first was that the
President had to get approval from a
federal judge the second was that the
insurrection act could be used until
Congress came back into session and then
had to approve the you
of the military now those two
restrictions on the insurrection act
sunset it out and no longer are part of
the act and no longer act as a check
against use of military personnel under
the insurrection act so when has the
insurrection act exception been used to
Posse Comitatus now although the
insurrection act has not been used
frequently presidents have invoked it to
enforce the law especially when racial
equality is at stake in 1957 President
Eisenhower called on the US Army's 101st
Airborne Division to safely escort nine
black students into Little Rock Central
High School after the Arkansas governor
Orval Faubus had called on the Arkansas
National Guard to stop the students from
integrating the school
President Kennedy invoked the act in
1962 and 1963 to send federal troops to
Mississippi in Alabama to enforce civil
rights laws in 1967 President Johnson
sent the 82nd and 101st Airborne
Division's to Detroit to quell riots
between police and residents after
Martin Luther King jr. was assassinated
and in 1992 President HW Bush responded
to a request from Governor Pete Wilson
of California to quell riding in Los
Angeles after the acquittal of the four
LAPD officers who brutally beat Rodney
King there are 3,000 National Guardsmen
on duty in the city of Los Angeles and
let me assure you I will use whatever
force is necessary to restore order so
in modern times the presidential use of
the insurrection Act has generally been
used to enforce civil rights and
integration and racial equality rather
than the opposite and it's generally
been used in ways that most people would
find unobjectionable at least in this
day and age and sometimes that use of
the insurrection Act was explicitly
against the wishes of the state
governors for example Governor Faubus
had improperly used the state National
Guard to disregard federal court orders
regarding integration of students and in
that example he certainly did not want
the federal government's assistance of
in fact that ran completely contrary to
what he wanted governor Wilson on the
other hand did ask for help from
President Bush and the other instances
also involved quelling of riots that
were explicit responses to racial
injustice and there's probably one other
historical example that is
relevant and that was the federal
government's response to Hurricane
Katrina when the levees in Louisiana
broke the state and federal government
were slow to respond to the enormous
logistical challenges in humanitarian
crisis President Bush considered
invoking the insurrection act but the
Department of Defense was concerned that
Americans would be reluctant to see the
military in that role and at the time
the military was fighting two wars and
eventually Congress amended the
insurrection act clarifying the
circumstances that would justify the use
of Armed Forces there is now language in
the statute that lets the President use
the military to restore order and
enforce the federal laws if there is a
natural disaster epidemic or terrorist
act though ultimately the Bush
administration decided not to invoke the
insurrection act in support of
humanitarian efforts regarding Katrina
and it's probably important to talk
about the distinction between norms and
laws the law itself has been pretty
broad for a very long time but it's
revealing the president's have been
reluctant to invoke the insurrection act
that is a presidential norm a societal
norm but it is not written in to the act
and you can see how a broadly written
law that has been used in some instances
where no one would object and probably
other instances that were closer to the
margins can be used for good and ill
depending on who is upholding the norms
and who is not and the Katrina example
is important because it reveals two
concerns that normally come up when
there's a situation requiring a national
response and that also involves the
difference between norms and laws first
the American people have traditionally
been very wary about military operating
on US soil this in turn has made the
military wary of being deployed for
civilian matters and there are very good
policy reasons that should probably be
pretty obvious as to why you don't want
a military doing law enforcement
activity and why you want a strong
separation between a military that's
trained to kill and a police force that
is trained to serve and protect and
second the Bush administration had a
significant debate about whether to
invoke the act members of Congress
weighed in and so did all 50 governors
under normal administrations both
Democratic and Republican there's a
decision-making process where the
president hears from stakeholders about
the
and cons of using the military that
doesn't mean the president lacks the
power to use the military or enforce the
law on the contrary the president
clearly has the discretion to involve
the military in civilian affairs under
these different acts even if the
governors don't ask for help but rather
it signals that at least in modern times
we've had presidents who thought about
what the governor's might want how the
people might react and whether a
military response would actually make
things worse and it's hard not to think
about the historical example of Caesar
crossing the Rubicon that sometimes the
norms involving the lack of
participation by the military and
domestic affairs or at least crossing
the Rubicon into Rome that that norm
exists for a very very good reason and
it's also probably worth pointing out
that the Posse Comitatus Act in
conjunction with the insurrection act
contemplate that the president is going
to faithfully execute the laws and that
on that basis the president probably has
a lot of discretion to use the military
to stop riots in the name of enforcing
the laws because we have a lot of laws
out there and it's hard to not think
about this fact without examining the
context of what actually happened when
the president mentioned invoking the
insurrection act that while he was
giving his speech in the Rose Garden
that he or bill Barr gave orders to
clear out the protesters in Lafayette
Square so that the president could get
his photo op at st. John's Church to
clear a path for the president's
impromptu walk the u.s. federal Park
Police used OC gas pepper sprays rubber
bullets and flash bangs on a crowd of
peaceful protesters all this happened
before the 7:00 p.m. curfew and of
course the right to protest to peaceably
assemble is part of the First Amendment
this is part of the freedom of
expression that all Americans enjoy
protests are a way of life in Washington
DC which is to be expected this is after
all the seat of government but it
doesn't mean the president's Trump's
actions on Monday were necessarily
illegal in the strictest sense over the
last several decades courts have allowed
government to make more restrictions on
the time place and manner of protests as
long as those restrictions are what's
called content neutral and you can
imagine how some of these laws conflict
with individual citizens
right to First Amendment activity to
petition the government to peaceably
assemble and to protest there are in
fact many statutes that make it clear
that protesters cannot block access to
federal buildings or destroy private
property or stop the president from
going somewhere he wants to go but you
can also imagine how some of these laws
might be used as a pretext to quell
First Amendment expressive activity and
one of the things that made president
Trump's actions so incendiary is that he
wasn't on his way to the Capitol to meet
with Congress nor was he doing anything
strictly related to the business of
being president instead he just had an
impromptu photo op that appears to be
used for his re-election campaign that
wasn't planned out and specifically
conflicted with the protestors who were
already there and we're already
protesting peaceably using their First
Amendment rights but that's the
difference between norms and things that
are written into the law and perhaps
we've just been lucky that prior to now
we haven't had such a bumbling example
of a pretext used to evacuate people
exercising their their First Amendment
rights in front of the White House and
the same goes for the use of troops and
military and federal officers throughout
DC and the rest of the country even
President Nixon never placed soldiers at
the foot of the Lincoln Memorial
blocking the American people from
accessing one of its most significant
memorials which we have seen that the
Trump administration has done and it's
been a long time since all of Lafayette
Square and such a significant portion of
downtown Washington DC has been
completely locked off from protesters or
even tourists I participated in the
women's March in 2017 there were tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people who were allowed to walk right
in front of the White House and even
that wouldn't be available based on
what's going on right now and in fact in
a direct historical parallel when mass
protests erupted after students were
killed by the National Guard at Kent
State University then President Nixon
left the White House and met with
protesters personally at the Lincoln
Memorial this surreal event eventually
led to Nixon creating a formal study of
campus unrest
during the Vietnam War but because of
Washington DC's unique position as a
federal district rather than a state and
because of its disenfranchisement the
federal government has authority to use
federal troops and military police
officers in the limits of Washington DC
in a way that they actually can't do
outside of the district so if it sounds
like president Trump has a lot of power
he does presidents in general have a lot
of power to use the military for
different ends but as things stand it's
up in the air it's not clear that the
president has actually invoked the
insurrection act Secretary of Defense
Mike Esper has voiced his opinion that
the president should not in fact invoke
the insurrection act and should refrain
from using the US military to conduct
law enforcement and anti-riot actions
the option to use active duty forces in
a law enforcement role should only be
used as a matter of last resort and only
in the most urgent and dire of
situations we are not in one of those
situations now so it's not clear how
long he's going to be the Secretary of
Defense but you can imagine that if the
Secretary of Defense is urging the
president not to use troops in this
context that it's not surprising that
people are going to protest to the use
of this kind of force in addition to
protesting the police brutality that
we've seen throughout the country but
unfortunately if you're out there
protesting this use of the military and
police brutality there's a chance that
you might be illegally arrested for your
First Amendment activity and if you are
arrested and you need to make your one
phone call to get your lawyer to get you
out of jail then at least you can use
t-mobile and save some money and as a
bonus the call with your civil rights
lawyer will be super clear Ching Mobile
is a different kind of mobile provider
with ting you only pay for your actual
data and services you use at the end of
the month and because you're paying for
only what you actually use 10 customers
pay on average just $23 per month for
one device and ting provides great LTE
coverage because it uses the t-mobile
Sprint and the Verizon network so you
get the benefit of three massive
networks wherever you go which can be
important when you've been unfairly
detained in federal jail and with ting
you can use almost any cell phone
including the newest iPhones and pixel
phones and you can use the same phone
number you're using right now there's no
contra
overage fees or any other carrier tricks
you just paid a fair price for the talk
text and data that you use up every
month and ting has award-winning
customer service because they don't have
any brick-and-mortar stores they pour
all of their resources into their phone
and online support if you have any
issues you can just give them a call and
you'll immediately talk to a real human
being and they might be able to hook you
up with a lawyer with ting especially if
you're around Wi-Fi all the time which
most of us are considering we're working
from home owner federal jails have Wi-Fi
you'll end up paying way less than you
do now of course some people should pay
$200 a month for unlimited data if
they're nowhere near their homes but if
you're surrounded by Wi-Fi all day long
you might be paying hundreds of dollars
more completely unnecessarily and ting
gives you the option to pay only for
what you use so if you go to legal Eagle
ENCOM you can use your last bill to
compare just how much you would save and
legal eagles will get a twenty five
dollar credit by going to legal eagle
ENCOM that could cover your entire first
month and since there are no contracts
you can try it for a month no strings
attached again all you have to do is
click the link in the description or go
to legal eagle ENCOM and get a twenty
five dollar credit for whatever service
you want plus clicking on the link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis do you think that
we should amend the Posse Comitatus and
insurrection act laws to make it harder
to use troops on American soil
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist with all of
my other real law reviews talking about
the crazy stuff happening with protests
and kovat 19 and basically all of the
news there's a lot of it so click on
this playlist and I'll see you in court
hopefully not literally